the nights are cold in Nepal's Ram
District but these people have no choice
but to sleep here and wait for
help after a powerful earthquake
destroyed their homes they only have
blankets and a small fire to keep them
warm our village has been totally
destroyed we don't have anything left to
eat whatever food we had is bed under
the rubble of our fallen heart houses
she says they are surviving by eating
rice and
salt most houses in this area were
damaged or destroyed in Friday's
earthquake the government should help us
as our houses and everything has been
[Applause]
lost authorities estimate at least 200
people were injured when the earthquake
struck in the middle of the
night
I was sleeping on the top floor the
middle floor totally collapsed and I was
thrown I thought I would die for sure
but here I am I
survived earthquakes are common in Nepal
but this is the worst to hit since
2015 officials are still trying to find
survivors or the dead in destroyed
homes cremations are underway
for I found that my daughter my
son-in-law and Grandson had died it took
us 2 hours to take their bodies out and
bring them
here many people here now face immense
difficulties unsure of what they will
eat or where they will sleep and the
most difficult challenge saying goodbye
to their loved
ones Jessica Washington Al
jazer